foreign
[Music]
it's a campaign of vaccination against
gang violence the work Halle will
continue to eradicate the kidnapping
virus in the country
[Music]
I'm here in the neighborhood of Bel-Air
this area used to be filled with people
but as you can see right now it's almost
empty it looks like a war zone there's
been fighting going on between rival
gangs we're told that members of the G9
gang are not far away from here and they
have been attacking this area
[Music]
oh
this should be a force a multilateral
force with the leadership of one country
whatever country
unfortunately there's no country who has
been able to accept this these great
challenge
and so now we are at the point that we
require innovative ways to find
different solutions
[Music]
[Applause]